>> Alright Charles, what, you said you had
the answer how do we figure it out?
>> It's 1 6th.
>> I guess that's what, which, we don't, I don't know if it will accept that,
whatever 1 6th is expressed as a decimal, but yes 1 6th. How did you get that?
>> I saw the number six and figured it had to
be 1 6th because you said it was low, but here is
what actually I did, well, I was thinking about it is, you
said, well when are they equally good? Well, if you always defect,
you get minus 6 gamma over 1 minus
gamma. And if you always cooperate, you get minus
1 over minus 1 minus gamma, so they're
equally good when those two values are the same.
>> Good, alright, and the denominators are the
same, as long as gamma's not one, that's fine.
>> Right.
>> If we divide by the negative 6, we get gamma equals 1 6th.
>> Exactly.
>> Excellent. So, so that's interesting, right? So,
that's, it's saying that for gamma values that are
less than 1 6th, we should be doi, we should just defect because there's
no. Well the games not going to last long enough for us to form any
kind of coalition. But for things higher than 1 6th. A half. 3 quarters.
0.999. It's going to be better to cooperate than to defect against tit for tat.
>> Or 6 plus epsilon.
>> Indeed.
>> Yeah. I like that. That's actually very cool.